taking over this plane cell phone video
captured the frightening moments aboard
a flight from Los Angeles to Boston
Sunday officials say Francisco Torres
threatened other passengers and crew
members he said he wanted to jump out of
the plane and attempted to open a cabin
door they say he then tried to stab a
flight attendant in the neck with a
broken metal spoon before other
passengers and crew took him down that
person was
right now
how quietly he's just laying there with
six able bodies on top of him the flight
attendant was not seriously injured
Torres is under arrest and could face
life in prison and yesterday two United
planes clipped their wings while on the
tarmac and Boston Logan investigators
say it happened when one United Plane
being towed made contact with another
that was parked at the neighboring gate
no one was injured